okay i'm like okay i'm thinking she's
packing
she comes back what about this dress
i'm like that look like the last dress
and she's like i know it's different i'm
like okay looks great
you know i like that one too
five six six dresses y'all she come back
now i know this for one of the dresses i
gotta act like i don't like it because
if i say i like every dress shane gonna
believe that i think that she ain't
gonna bleed my opinion on any of the
dresses so even though they all look
great on her she looks great and these
guys she's freaking she's a freaking
fashion model so clothes look great on
her they built for her frame you know
this next dress she come in i gotta go i
go i don't like that one i think the
other two are better just so we can it
seemed like i'm you know what i'm saying
so she
she goes back come in two more dresses i
go these all look great we only going
for one night y'all we going for one
night
[Music]